100 millions de téléspectateurs des
dizaines de millions de visionnements en
ligne les publicités sortent encore
gagnante du super bowl selon youtube les
publicités d'amazon de facebook et de
jeep ont été les plus populaires cette
année parmi les thèmes récurrents
l'espace les produits pour femmes les
messages prônant l'égalité des sexes
publicité - dire aussi pour google qui
enjoint la carte l'émotion a illustré
l'éventail des formations de son système
conserve même sur les défunts soulevant
encore l'enjeu de confidentialité et à
chaque super beau sa controverse
brassicole cette fois avec michael leib
qui promet qu'en achetant sa bière le
consommateur appuie la conversion à
l'agriculture bio du tape à l'oeil selon
le gouvernement de l'iowa puisqu'il
faudrait vendre au moins 15 millions de
canettes pour appuyer le virage d'un
seul petit producteur
[Musique]